Leanne:
This is my family...
...and I will not
let you take me away from them!
♪♪
♪ Here we go. ♪
♪ Hello Matthew ♪
♪ Little bumblebee, we're s-- ♪
♪ So glad to see you ♪
♪ How about Ella ♪
A toast...
to motherhood...
and to new beginnings.
♪ Everyone buzz like a bee. ♪
Can I tell you something silly?
Sometimes I feel like I'm cursed.
I think that everything's happening
the way that it's supposed to.
This cult could come back
for her at any time.
None of you can protect me from them.
You wouldn't even know what to look for.
Are you feeding
those squatters again, Sean?
They're hungry kids, Dorothy.
What if they're casing the place?
I forbid you to go back to that park.
It's so funny how controlling you can be.
I think it would be best for everyone
if you were able to
make peace with Leanne.
Why are you both so afraid of her?
She's angry.
I see.
Please don't hurt her.
Julian, you're not telling me everything.
What is going on?
There's a price to pay.
What the hell happens now?
The end.
I don't wanna lose my son again.
Things are decaying.
She's gotta go.
The house is filled with pests.
She's like this worm
that gets under your skin.
This is my home.
This is my family...
...and I will not
let you take me away from them!
God didn't bring back Jericho.
Then, who did?